В ефірі випуск новин «heute» з Мітрієм Сіріним.
Добрий вечір.
А також Катя Штрезо - з новинами спорту.
Сьогодні в ефірі порушуватимемо такі питання:
Голод як зброя:
президентка Єврокомісії
назвала ганебним блокування
Росією постачання українського зерна
і провокування продовольчих криз.
Щонайменше вісім підтверджених випадків:
міністр охорони здоров'я рекомендує
три тижні ізоляції
інфікованим мавпячою віспою у Німеччині.
Побиті та принижені:
показові фото з Китаю демонструють,
як поліцейські систематично катують
мусульман-уйгурів
у таборах перевиховання.
Вже три місяці ми живемо в докорінно
іншому світі.
Рівно три місяці триває війна в Україні.
На Всесвітньому економічному форумі в Давосі
президентка Єврокомісії
фон дер Ляєн звинуватила Росію у використанні
голоду як зброї.
Детальніше про це розповість наш
кореспондент в Україні.
Але перед цим - Анне Гелінек
про другий день форуму у Давосі,
під час якого, зокрема, обговорювали
фінансові наслідки війни.
Не можна звинувачувати конференцію у Давосі
в надмірному блиску.
Замість червоної доріжки - білі картонні двері,
з яких до фотографів виходять почесні гості.
Сьогодні серед них була й президентка Єврокомісії
Урсула фон дер Ляєн.
У її промові йшлося про заплановану відбудову України,
яку Єврокомісія хотіла б координувати
за посередництва агенції
та фінансувати коштами російських олігархів.
Наголошую, що це непросто, але я вважаю
це справедливо,
що ми робимо все можливе,
щоб Росія також зробила свій внесок
у відбудову України.
Спірним залишається питання про те,
де європейці мають взяти гроші
і чи можуть бути «спільні борги»,
як у разі з фондом відбудови після пандемії
«Next Generation EU».
Німеччина відразу ж відхилила цю ідею.
Щодо Німеччини, я повинен заявити,
що про запозичення моделі «Next Generation EU»
не може бути й мови.
Війна в Україні також змінює риторику
щодо світової торгівлі.
У своєму визначному виступі
генеральний секретар НАТО Столтенберг
застерігає стривожену бізнес-еліту
від ведення бізнесу з авторитарними державами.
Свобода важливіша за вільну торгівлю.
Захист наших цінностей важливіший за прибуток.
Давос переосмислює глобалізацію.
Тема України - панівний лейтмотив
і ﻿під час другого дня Всесвітнього економічного
форуму.
Водночас зростає занепокоєння
щодо глобальної продовольчої кризи,
яку Путін посилює цілеспрямованими блокадами.
Давос також шукає відповідь на це питання.
Три місяці тому російські війська розпочали масове вторгнення
в Україну.
Вони не змогли взяти Київ,
і наступ на Півночі України провалився.
Відтоді атаки зосереджені на Донбасі,
на Сході країни.
На Півдні України, на березі Чорного моря,
розташований Миколаїв -
морський центр із важливими торговими портами.
Росія їх блокує,
тому населення Близького Сходу та
Північної Африки страждає від голоду.
Однак ситуація може дедалі погіршитися.
Репортаж з України - Йоганнес Гано.
Зараз це одна з найнебезпечніших професій у світі -
фермер в Україні.
Ми їдемо зі старшим лейтенантом 63-ї бригади
Олегом Зелінським.
Ми перебуваємо у червоній зоні на Південному
фронті в Миколаївській області.
На ґрунтовій дорозі перед нами трактор,
який потрапив на міну.
Фермер загинув.
Військовий захоплюється мужністю фермерів.
Я можу сказати лише, що це був герой.
Я український військовий.
Селяни воюють на економічному фронті,
щоб уникнути голоду у цілому світі.
Через кілька кілометрів
фермер Володимир Онищук показує нам те,
з чим їм щодня доводиться стикатися.
Вирва від бомби посеред ріпакового поля.
Російський винищувач розбомбив його поля.
Вони бомбардують наші села і поля.
Ми знаходимо їхні бомби в місцях,
де взагалі немає військових.
Цьогорічний урожай буде поганим,
російські війська грабують тутешніх фермерів.
Вони крадуть зернозбиральні комбайни
та сільськогосподарську техніку.
Вони крадуть зерно і насіння
і вивозять все в Росію та Крим.
Урожай, ймовірно, буде набагато меншим
через війну,
а ще є проблема з торішнім урожаєм.
Понад 20 млн тонн зерна та іншої
сільськогосподарської продукції
не можуть бути експортовані,
оскільки порти в Одесі та Миколаєві
заблоковані російським флотом.
Склади повні, а нового врожаю ще немає.
Блокади портів мусять бути зняті,
адже це не лише наша проблема.
Це проблема всього світу.
Морська блокада,
напади на українське сільське господарство.
Голод стає зброєю для Росії в цій війні,
до того ж у країні, яка забезпечує основними
харчовими продуктами сотні мільйонів людей
у ​​всьому світі.
Війна в Україні стала головною темою
під час останньої зупинки у поїздці
канцлера Шольца до Африки.
У Преторії він зустрівся з президентом
Південної Африки Рамафосою.
Щодо війни були явні розбіжності.
Південна Африка утримується від засудження
російського нападу.
З іншого боку, є спільні погляди
щодо питань енергетики.
Південна Африка постачатиме вугілля,
щоб компенсувати його нестачу з Росії.
Зі свого боку Німеччина допоможе
у розвитку відновлюваних джерел енергії.
Досвід пандемії останніх двох років залишив
свої сліди.
Оскільки кількість випадків захворювання мавпячою віспою
зростає у всьому світі,
скрізь панує невизначеність.
У Європі повідомляють про вже понад 100 підтверджених випадків
та вісім - у Німеччині.
Міністр охорони здоров'я Лаутербах зазначає, що
потрібно серйозно поставитися до цієї небезпеки
та вжити заходів із її стримування.
Але нової пандемії він не передбачає.
Далі Сабіне Комм і Кай Ніклаш.
Міністр охорони здоров'я
Карл Лаутербах
тепер має проявити себе під час нового виклику:
мавпяча віспа.
Вона часто зустрічається у чоловіків,
які займаються незахищеним статевим актом
з іншими чоловіками.
Непокоїть те, що спалахи у світі дуже
відрізняються від тих,
що були раніше, але:
актуальна ситуація з мавпячою віспою
не є передвісником нової пандемії.
Наскільки нам відомо,
спалахи цього захворювання
були дуже частими,
і його можна контролювати,
якщо добре відстежувати контакти
і бути обачними.
Серед симптомів зазначають високу температуру,
головний біль, біль у м'язах та висипання.
Однак новим є дослідження про те, що багато людей,
які заразилися в Європі,
останнім часом не їздили до Африки.
Європейський варіант, певно, м'якший,
а також перебіг полегшує те,
що у 70-х роках на Заході
та у 80-х роках на Сході
все ще проводилася вакцинація проти віспи.
Тож було вироблено імунітет,
але він стає дедалі слабшає,
якщо більше часу минає від вакцинації
і що довше інфікований той,
хто був щеплений.
Проте кількість заходів зменшують.
Німеччина замовила 40 000 доз вакцини.
Міністр охорони здоров'я Німеччини зазначив,
що наша країна не перебуває напередодні пандемії.
Мавпяча віспа -
нова хвороба, багато питань.
Ми зібрали для вас відповіді в нашому додатку.
Які симптоми і шляхи передачі?
Як можна захистити себе?
І багато іншого.
Нова рекомендація від
Постійної комісії з вакцинації.
Тепер вона радить щеплювати від коронавірусу
всіх дітей віком від п'яти до одинадцяти років,
навіть тих, хто вже був інфікований.
Однієї дози достатньо для створення
базового імунітету.
Досі рекомендації щодо вакцинації стосувалися тільки
для дітей із перенесеними раніше захворюваннями
або для тих, хто контактував з людьми
з групи ризику.
Про внутрішню політику:
цікаво поглянути, що відбувається після виборів
у Шлезвіг-Гольштайні та
Північному Рейні-Вестфалії.
Результати обговорюють в обох
федеральних землях,
як на Заході, так і на Півночі,
і зараз це схоже на чорно-зелений уряд.
Явним переможцем виборів стала CDU,
Зелені досягли значних успіхів.
У Шлезвіг-Гольштайні
коаліційні переговори можуть розпочатися вже
завтра.
Досі існувала «Ямайська коаліція»,
що складалася з CDU, Зелених та FDP.
У Північному Рейні-Вестфалії FDP теж,
ймовірно, залишить уряд.
І все скоро може стати «чорно-зеленим».
Погляньмо на Кіль разом із Германом Берндом
і почнімо з Томасом Мюнтеном у Дюссельдорфі.
Вони обидва приходять пішки,
хочуть здаватися привітними,
розмовляють із демонстрантами біля дверей
і демонструють один до одного свою приязнь.
Мона Нойбаур та Гендрік Вюст сьогодні побували
з великими делегаціями
на першій ознайомчій зустрічі у Дюссельдорфі.
У тематичному плані до вітроенергетики,
бурого вугілля та транспорту ще далеко.
Але ми відчуваємо готовність об'єднуватися.
У наших партій різні пріоритети,
і це добре.
Тепер ціль має полягати в тому,
щоб знайти спільні відповіді
на найважливіші питання щодо майбутнього
нашої країни.
Людям у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії потрібен уряд,
який йде в ногу з часом.
Ми готові та з нетерпінням чекаємо на
спільні переговори.
До вихідних має бути підготовлений
перший документ,
на підставі якого Зелені хочуть вирішити
на малій партійній конференції,
чи вступати до коаліційних переговорів.
До цього моменту обидві сторони домовилися
зберігати мовчання.
Доброго ранку.
У Кілі тепло приймають.
Даніель Гюнтер знає Зелених
як надійних партнерів з часів «Ямайки».
Проте попередній тристоронній альянс зазнав
невдачі під час обговорень.
Із Зеленими як єдиним партнером
і значною більшістю голосів за нього
Гюнтер хоче досягти амбітних цілей
щодо захисту клімату
і поєднати їх зі збільшенням кількості
робочих місць.
Але ми також хочемо розставити власні
пріоритети, наприклад,
у розширенні інфраструктури, внутрішньої
безпеки чи у сфері сільського господарства.
Ми набрали 43,4% голосів,
і це, звісно, має бути закріплено
у коаліційній угоді.
І саме тому ми мужньо та впевнено
йдемо на переговори.
Завтра Даніель Гюнтер планує
розпочати коаліційні перемовини.
Він бажає швидко досягти своєї мети
у «чорно-зеленому» союзі.
На зв'язку зі столичної студії -
Шакунтала Банерджі.
Отже, все вказує на те, що
земельний парламент і в Шлезвіг-Гольштайні,
і в Північному Рейні-Вестфалії очолить
«чорно-зелений» союз.
Що це означає для керівної
«світлофорної» коаліції в Берліні?
Вочевидь, лібералів і SPD має сильно непокоїти те,
що CDU і Зелені так швидко
знаходять спільну мову.
Хоча земельна політика - не те саме,
що федеральна, але з цього зближення
можна зробити два висновки.
По-перше, партії FDP не вдається
досягти власної мети -
неодмінно гарантувати собі місце в коаліції,
навіть там, де, як вони думають,
добре проявили себе.
По-друге, SPD не вдається зробити
модель «світлофорної» коаліції
настільки привабливою,
щоб завадити Зеленим скористатися
новими політичними можливостями.
Усе це збільшить тиск на FDP й SPD у Берліні
щодо профілювання
й ускладнить спільне правління
«світлофорної» коаліції.
Дякую. А зараз подивімося на іншу партію:
після провалу на виборах і багатьох конфліктів
всередині партії Ліві хочуть почати все спочатку.
Окрім Яніне Вісслер, чинної лідерки партії,
на співголовування претендують два чоловіки:
депутат Європейського парламенту
Мартін Шірдеван
і депутат Бундестагу з Лейпцига
Серен Пельман.
Останній заявив у Берліні, що прагне
покінчити з «боротьбою Лівих проти самих себе»
й повернутися до концепції
«боротьби за ідеали лівих».
Вже впродовж тривалого часу Китай чинить опір
проти закидів, які надходять з лав
правозахисних організацій.
Ті звинувачують владу Пекіна в утримуванні
понад мільйона уйгурів
та інших мусульманських меншин
у так званих «таборах перевиховання»
і силуванні до примусової праці.
Ймовірно, тепер відкидати
ці звинувачення стане ще складніше,
адже почали масово з'являтися нові докази цього:
фотографії, заяви, офіційні вказівки,
які засвідчують обурливі порушення прав людини.
Більше розкаже Ульф Реллер з Пекіна.
На цих жахливих кадрах можна побачити,
як жорстоко правителі Китаю
пригноблюють уйгурів.
Це тисячі доказів масового інтернування
і культурного знищення мусульманської меншини.
Це фото 2018 року
з табору перевиховання в Сіньцзяні.
Адріанові Ценцу надіслали ці дані анонімно.
Уже впродовж багатьох років
він досліджує долю уйгурів.
Ці дані є безсумнівним доказом того,
що табори перевиховання нагадують в'язницю.
Документи чітко вказують на те,
як охороняють табори
і яку зброю застосовує поліція.
Ймовірно, в Сіньцзяні розташовано
понад 300 таборів.
За наявними даними,
Китай останніми роками інтернував
мільйон представників мусульманських меншин.
Ці документи показують, хто саме став жертвою.
Міжнародна спільнота має моральний обов'язок
зупинити цей геноцид.
Уже немає підстав мовчати,
адже з'явилися нові докази.
Сьогодні Комісарка ООН з прав людини
зустрілася з міністром закордонних справ Китаю.
Він не хотів нічого пояснювати,
а лише говорив про брехню «антикитайських сил».
Міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини
Бербок вимагає роз'яснення.
Для мене важливо, аби щодо вже давно відомих звинувачень
з боку Китаю
відстежувалася чітка позиція.
Китайський уряд не хоче, щоб світ побачив ці кадри.
Під час перегляду документів сторінка зникає.
Ми підозрюємо, що за цим стоять
представники китайського уряду.
Також, за повідомленням
організації «Amnesty International»,
у Китаї минулого року віддали на страту
тисячі людей - знову рекордну у світі кількість.
Точну кількість жертв уряд приховує,
як це робить також Північна Корея та В’єтнам.
Де-факто представники «Amnesty» зафіксували
щонайменше 579 здійснених страт у 18 країнах.
У порівнянні з минулим роком,
кількість страт зросла на 20%,
зокрема через послаблення
протиепідемічних заходів.
Найбільше страт зареєстрували
в Ірані, Єгипті, Саудівській Аравії й Сирії.
У музеях колишніх колоніальних країн
можна знайти багато скарбів,
викрадених у пригноблених народів,
часто - із застосуванням сили.
Тривалий час цю історію замовчували,
але тепер настали інші часи,
зокрема й у Берліні.
Рік тому Федеральний уряд визнав свою провину
за злочини колоніальної епохи й зараз починає
повертати награбовані витвори мистецтва
зокрема до Намібії, колишньої колонії
Німецька Південно-Західна Африка.
Подробиці - в сюжеті Наді Нассер.
Традиційний головний убір жінок народу гереро,
давні прикраси, інструменти, ляльки,
зокрема предмети з намібійських
королівських домів.
Повідомляють, що тепер, за майже 100 років,
неоціненні твори мистецтва
повертають на батьківщину.
Ці предмети вивезли з Намібії
без згоди нашого народу, намібійців.
Тому ця ініціатива дуже важлива.
Але це лише перший крок на довгому шляху.
З 1400 предметів команда намібійських експертів
вибрала в Берліні 23, які становлять
особливу культурну цінність,
і разом з німецькими експертами
дослідила їхнє походження.
Деякі з них належать до об'єктів
«трофейного мистецтва» колоніальної епохи.
У тодішній Німецькій Південно-Західній Африці
правили жорстокі колоніальні господарі.
Десятки тисяч повстанців, представників народів
гереро і нама, вбили,
а культурні цінності вкрали.
Сьогодні більшість африканських творів мистецтва
перебувають у європейських музеях.
Берлінський етнологічний музей
хоче бути першим учасником
намібійського проєкту.
У всій суспільній свідомості, політиці,
в закладах культури щось змінилося,
як і в очікуваннях громадськості.
Ми повертаємо речі,
які отримали в контексті несправедливості.
Тож тепер ці предмети поїдуть до Намібії,
офіційно - як позика,
але, ймовірно, залишаться там назавжди -
і це лише перший маленький крок.
Тепер поговоримо про спорт.
Учора всі тремтіли, сьогодні ж -
зітхають з полегшенням, особливо в Берліні.
Берлінці перемогли в другому матчі на виліт
з рахунком 2:0 проти Гамбурга,
а отже, залишаються в Бундеслізі.
Однак у столичному клубі спокій
ще не запанував, а навпаки.
Директор клубу Фреді Бобич чекає
на значні заворушення
і конфлікти в колективі.
Усе добре, що добре закінчується.
Те, що вчора виглядало, як шкільна поїздка,
було спортивною боротьбою за виживання.
«Герта» залишається у вищій лізі
завдяки тимчасовому тренеру.
Це був абсолютно професійний виступ
команди, яка від самого початку
завзято боролася.
Місце в лізі вибороли,
але тепер на футбольну команду
чекають великі зміни.
Перша Бундесліга залишається в Берліні.
Ми просто радіємо, і завтра
я знатиму, для чого працюю.
Маґат пішов, менеджер має спочатку
знайти нового тренера.
Він має бути винятковою особистістю
й принести вогонь,
усе віддати «Герті»,
бути відданим нашому важкому шляху.
Без інвестора нічого не вдасться.
Президент Ґеґенбауер
нещодавно пішов у відставку
після 14 років головування клубом.
«Герта» ще вчора була на колінах, але досі живе.
Тепер вона хоче знову підвестися.
Поки «Герта» ще шукає тренера,
його вже офіційно знайшла команда Вольфсбурга.
Як уже всі здогадувалися, ним стане Ніко Ковач,
попередньо до 2025 року.
Андре Брайтенрайтер тренуватиме «Гоффенгайм».
Його контракт чинний до 2024 року.
Національна збірна Німеччини з хокею
програла свій останній матч
проти Швейцарії з рахунком 3:4.
Неймовірний гол Маттіаса Плахти приніс
німецькій команді рахунок 3:3,
тож вона відіграла серію пенальті.
Вирішальний удар був за швейцарцем Ріатом.
Німеччина посіла друге місце в команді.
Наступним суперником у чвертьфіналі післязавтра
буде або олімпійський чемпіон Фінляндія,
або 12-разовий чемпіон світу Чехія.
Професійна тенісистка Анджелік Кербер
вперше за чотири роки знову виступила
в другому турі на Відкритому
чемпіонаті Франції з тенісу
проти Маґдалени Френх з Польщі.
Німкеня відбила два матчболи
і після всього перемогла з рахунками 2:6, 6:3 і 7:5.
Завтра змагатимуться зокрема
Андреа Петкович і Александр Звєрєв.
Щиро дякую, Катю.
А тепер про погоду: на Півночі й Півдні
хмарність збільшиться й принесе зливу,
а в інших регіонах погода буде кращою.
Про це незабаром розповість Кріста Орбен.
Ми ж радимо подивитися новий випуск
«heute journal» о 21:45
з Марієттою Сломкою у розмові з
Урсулою фон дер Ляєн.
Щиро дякую, гарного вечора й до зустрічі.
Завтра в цей час в ефірі
буде Барбара Гальвеґ. Бережіть себе.
Вітаю! Погляньмо на погоду.
Сьогодні вона була досить мінливою й вітряною.
Через вплив західних вітрів
погода такою й залишатиметься.
Також стане трохи прохолодніше.
Сьогодні ввечері на термометрі переважно
однозначні числа: від 6 до 12°,
а в районах біля гір Айфель
температура може впасти до 3°.
Уночі переважно без опадів,
але між Баварським лісом
й Альпами дощитиме й далі.
Там уже вночі у вівторок почався невеликий дощ.
На Південному сході так буде й завтра вранці.
Хмарність збільшиться, дощ повільно
перейде у короткочасні зливи,
а потім припиниться.
Грозові зливи будуть і в прибережній зоні
передусім ближче до вечора,
вітер з Південного заходу значно посилиться.
Між цими районами проходить смужка
з Південного заходу до Бранденбурга,
тут буде переважно сухо і до обіду досить сонячно.
У цій смузі завтра температури
сягатимуть 20-24°,
а в інших регіонах - 16-20°.
Такі ж температури чекають нас на свято,
Вознесіння Господнє - 16-24°.
На Півдні буде сонячніше,
на Півночі - досить хмарно з невеликими зливами
і вітер з грозовими шквалами біля моря з заходу.
У п’ятницю й суботу буде й надалі
вітряна й мінлива погода.
Також буде трохи прохолодніше.
У суботу очікуємо лише 14-20°.
До побачення.